a blink and you'll miss it black panther
related cameo in thor 4 could have
massive story ramifications for phase 4
of the mcu keep watching for the major
black panther cameo you probably missed
in thor love and thunder warning
spoilers ahead thor love and thunder is
out in theaters now and the titular hero
is up against a new foe gord and god
butcher is on a mission to kill all gods
across the universe a ruthless rampage
that leads him to the shores of new
asgard while gore's actions threaten to
usher in a new age of chaos thor is
faced with the return of his
ex-girlfriend dr jane foster who now
bears a mantle of the mighty thor it's a
complicated time for the god of thunder
jane
one of the film's cause trends is that
it explores the mysterious lives of the
gods and goddesses that populate the
mythologies of various cultures although
we've seen norse gods like odin loki and
friga the latest thor franchise
installment introduced his viewers to a
variety of deities in omnipotent city a
gilded temple where guts can partake in
heavenly debauchery away from the woes
of mankind the star-studded lineup of
deities is key to the plot but also
provides the opportunity for levity
within a narrative that's as serious as
it is silly some of the faces of the
gods are more recognizable than others
including one figure who should be
familiar to fans of the mcu with gore
and possession of the necro sword our
heroes know that they'll need to raise a
formidable army to defeat him and ensure
the safe return of asgard's youth to
accomplish that goal thor jane valkyrie
and cork hitch up a converted amusement
park ride and head to omnipotent city
while thor tries to iron out a deal with
the inevitably pompous zeus viewers are
privy to a glimpse of the gods and
goddesses assembled including the
exceedingly adorable god of dumplings
however there's an even more interesting
idol in attendance the panther goddess
bast whose lore is extremely important
to the black panther franchise although
bast only appears in flashback as a
shadowy feline figure in the 2018 solo
film starring chadwick boseman viewers
finally get to see the goddess in full
physical form in thor love and thunder
played by actress and singer akasia
sabet bast returns to the mcu for the
first time since her premier appearance
knowing kevin feige's proclivity for
easter eggs and callbacks is unlikely to
be her last never forget you first her
visage isn't as bombastic as some of the
other deities seated around her but her
cattied helmets and golden ornaments
still draw the eye her appearance is
brief but her presence cements director
taika waititi's attention to detail even
though thor is off earth going on his
own adventures the moment reminds
viewers that the events of the film
correlate to a larger narrative within
the marvel canon the panther goddess has
been worshipped since around 10 000 bc
bast is an african deity that can take a
male or female form as the source of the
magic that imbues the black panther with
their powers bas is revered in wakanda
in the comics the late king t'challa's
sister shuri takes the opportunity to
stand before bus though she is deemed
too immature to become the next black
panther however shuri does eventually
take up the mantle and become queen of
wakanda a journey that could be utilized
for the upcoming film adaptation whether
or not wakanda forever makes use of that
particular storyline it makes sense that
the panther goddess would play some kind
of role in the narrative bast's
existence and omnipotent city could also
hint at what's to come in phase 4. the
goddess also has ties to victor von doom
who will ultimately become dr doom and
reed richard whose appearance in dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
could be teasing a classic marvel comic
story line called secret wars basta is
also the half sibling to the god khan
chu from moon knight a connection that
provides an opportunity for marvel to
flesh out the minor characters that's
introduced over the years
whatever it means for the big picture
bass appearance is a fun detail to look
out for whenever you watch thor love and
thunder
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
thor love and thunder are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you